foreign
good to see you I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report direct message we are
live streaming on Rumble UT YouTube and
Blaze TV don't forget to share subscribe
tap notification Bells it's March 8th
2022
there's a lot going on in the world uh I
said to my guys this morning like let's
just not do Russia Ukraine today the
whole thing you know they talk about the
fog of war the whole thing feels so
messy to me and so
uh confusing and I don't mean confusing
like like we can't ascertain truth out
of it I mean that our media is such in
such a state of disarray there are so
many liars everywhere people who have
lied about everything for so long that
trying to pill for some truth out of it
is really really tough
um you know as I said yesterday it's
like if you think the New York Times and
Washington Post lie about everything
then why would they not be lying about
this I don't know exactly
how to frame this in a way that is going
to make some sense to you and I think
also you know everybody pretends to be
an expert about absolutely everything
and I don't think I have to do that here
I will do the best I can to communicate
this stuff to you as honestly as
possible and we'll do more as as it
comes but I was just like you know I
just don't feel like doing it today if
you want a little more though on the
general
ideas about geopolitics and
international relations and things like
that I interviewed Nikki Haley who's the
former U.S ambassador to the UN we put
it up yesterday you know she was a U.N
Ambassador under Trump and I know
there's a little tension there between
the base and her for after the January 6
things and all that but she really lays
out an interesting case for you know
sort of peace through strength and you
know carry a big stick and speak softly
and all that good stuff and then I
talked to her about my more libertarian
approach to things so we have a really
interesting conversation uh part one is
up on YouTube the whole thing is up at
reubenreport.locals.com uh and uh as you
know I am in the midst of recording the
audiobook for don't burn this country
that's what I did for five hours after
the show yesterday and I'll be doing for
five hours after the show today the book
is on sale right now you can get it at
daverubin.com book that's the pre-sale
of course the book comes out on April
12th I think you're gonna dig it I'm
really enjoying doing the audiobook
because I can land all the funny stuff
and do it just exactly as I like with
the pauses in the right spots and all
that good stuff so I do think you will
dig it and as I said if you uh if you
buy it during the pre-sale time that
counts towards week one which gets us on
the New York Times and I only want to
get on the stupid list so that I can
tell those people to go after themselves
okay all of that being said today we're
going to be talking about uh this don't
say gay bill here in Florida and uh long
story short you can say gay and there's
actually nothing about gay in the
freaking Bill itself but everybody's
melting down and then we're gonna
compare and contrast what's going on
here in Florida which is at obviously
the Forefront the Forefront of Freedom
here in the United States versus what's
going on in places like California New
York and some other places when it comes
to the coveted stuff and believe it or
not in New York they still want young
toddlers in masks just crazy stuff but
before we get to any of that I want to
talk to you guys about back
and have a sip of coffee uh you know the
last two years have taught us anything
it's that you must take control of your
own health it's clear that you can't
simply rely on the government or big
Pharma to protect you or that your
family that's where Z stack comes in
z-stack is a specially formulated immune
boosting supplement that includes zinc
chrysleridin vitamin C and vitamin D
formulated by Dr Vlad zalenko the
world-renowned doctor president Trump
credited with his early treatment
protocol when he got coveted and his
decision to take take
hcq z-stack has been scientifically
formulated is kosher and GMP certified
and is produced right here in the USA
although Mass mandates are being lifted
and vaccine mandates are no longer
enforced in several States we'll get to
that in a little bit viruses are still
out there by taking Z stack daily or
supercharging your immune system z-stack
is formulated to help combat any and all
variants as well as the common cold and
flu so I encourage you to start taking
it now to stay stay ahead of any
potential future variants by preparing
your immune system and going about
living your life go to zstacklife.com
Dave today and enter the promo code Dave
to get a small discount off your first
order that's zstacklife.com Dave promo
code Dave and now back to me okay so the
big thing in the culture War which is
always raging on we are stuck in this
endless ridiculous culture war that
never stops and is fueled by algorithms
and liars and media buffoons
versus the rest of us uh the big thing
is this don't say gay bill that they're
telling us about in Florida now the bill
itself doesn't even have the word gay in
it uh but it has caused the complete
meltdown amongst our media Elite our
blue check Twitter Roddy and everyone
else uh so I'm going to tell you exactly
what's in the bill but before we do that
uh here's what's going on in uh Florida
schools this is Florida Senate Democrats
going to a school and in case you don't
know they love the gays
David
[Music]
these people are insane absolutely
insane uh that's out of school I think
we should just play it again
um what are they doing these are
supposed to be teachers
I'm gay she's gay everybody's gay
I'm honestly not sure that I'm gay after
this uh I'm married to a dude it's true
my husband's gay
um and that's uh you know is what it is
uh but I can't take these people anymore
and I'm thinking about returning the uh
the gay card these people are absolutely
ridiculous and actually joking aside if
you're pro-gay and what I mean by Pro
gay is if you meet if you believe that
that people uh have sexual preference
um and should be able to enter whatever
relationship they want with another
consenting adult if you if you
fundamentally believe that if you
believe in individual rights and all of
these things you have to be radically
against these people because these
people are making all gay people look
completely ridiculous and I actually
think there's an awful lot of gay people
that are completely against these people
now why is it that these adults are
parading around the school
chanting gay gay gay gay everybody's gay
you're gay you're gay extra credit if
you're gay why why is it that they're
doing it well it's because of this bill
that is in the Florida state senate
right now that they're calling the don't
say gay Bill and that sounds very scary
right oh my God you can't say gay but
we're for free speech why can't you say
gay
here is uh
uh the reporter Evan Donovan on uh local
Florida Channel explaining what is
actually in Bill 1557 and again the word
gay is not in it officially entitled
parental rights in education it forces
school districts to adopt procedures
that quote reinforce the fundamental
right of parents to make decisions
regarding the upbringing and control of
their children that includes making
school districts notify parents if there
are changes to the student's mental
emotional or physical health or
well-being not encouraging students to
withhold information from parents
allowing parents to access their child's
Student Records letting parents refuse
any health care services offered by the
school and getting parental permission
before administering any health
screening or well-being questionnaire
the bill also forces schools to respond
to parent concerns within a week and
resolve those issues within a month if
the school can't or won't parents can
escalate those concerns to the state for
a resolution or they can sue Okay so so
reporter Evan Donovan hit a little
run-in with DeSantis about this a day or
two ago we'll get to that in just a
second but what he laid out there is
basically what's in the bill to expand
on it a little bit more in the essence
if you are in kindergarten to third
grade that's what this is about
kindergarten to third grade they can't
teach you in a state school about
sexuality or gender identity
that has nothing to do with being
anti-gay or anti-trans or anything else
I really think about this for a second
or especially for those of you that are
parents really think about this thing
you got a second grader
second grader seven years old eight
years old okay I was just at my niece's
birthday party on Sunday she turned
seven years old these kids we were
playing we were making the the uh the
putty what do they call it not the putty
what do they make the Slime you make the
Slime it's like with shaving cream they
love slime and painting and all this
stuff it's a bunch of kids they want
nothing to do and they know nothing
about sexuality or sexual preference or
anything else why in the world would you
want to send your kid to a state-run
school where most likely an activist is
going to start bringing up sexual
attraction to them and sexual preference
and sexual identity whether they think
they're a boy or a girl or anything else
especially when you know that these
teachers are mostly activists and they
will always endorse the most extreme
ideas that's just true that's just true
that's not a that has nothing to do with
being gay or anything else why would you
want your young
kindergartner first grader second grader
third grader being taught about sex in
school that's what this is really about
but now can we pull up the still there
of the of the bullets of what else is in
there so this is HB 1557 this is what
all of the Democrats and the media are
going crazy about these people lie about
absolutely everything let's just go
quickly through these five bullets uh
what's in the bill they you should
notify parents of changes to health or
well-being well okay that does seem like
if a kid at school uh was having health
problems or seemed depressed or
something like that it does seem like
that shouldn't just be dealt with within
the school it seems like a teacher or an
administrator or principal might want to
communicate that to the parent because
ultimately the parent is the one
responsible for the child's well-being
okay bullet number two don't encourage
withholding info from parents well of
course that makes sense what right if
the school knew that a child was deeply
depressed about something was really
upset about something was in some sort
of pain having some sort of existential
crisis and again we're talking about
kids that are in first or second grade
this isn't about 10th graders right that
are a little more involved 12th graders
that are that are really figuring stuff
out of course you wouldn't want to
withhold that information if you had a
kid in school that was in a lot of pain
whatever that is physical pain mental
pain emotional pain why would you be
withholding that would that make sense
does does the state own the children not
yet bullet number three allow parents to
access child student records well okay
that that makes sense if a kid's acting
out in class and they get a bad Mark
he's talking a lot he makes a lot of
jokes whatever it might be of course the
parent should be able to see what's in
this kid's records again why why is the
good position here that we should hide
things from parents unless you guys are
up to something really nefarious and I
think you are bullet number four
let parents refuse school health care
services okay I could see this one being
slightly more controversial uh obviously
I'm okay with that of course parents
ultimately should decide what their
children are injected with or what pills
they take
etc etc we all know this I think that's
a I think that should be the default
position of most people
um but I suppose in the crazy world that
we live in it would be somewhat
controversial if some kids didn't want
to be injected and other kids did in
which case I think if you really care
about your kid you'll just take them out
of school but I'll at least Grant like
there's some debate there somewhere on
that one okay and the fifth bullet point
get parental permission for health
screening yeah okay that's fine why
wouldn't you just want a parent if you
go to the zoo remember when you went to
the zoo in school remember when you took
the trip to Washington DC and you went
and you saw the White House and all that
stuff you'd have to have a parental
document it was a small piece of paper
it was usually about you know yeah a yay
long and a parent would have to sign it
just to say okay I know my kid's going
somewhere so I think related to health
or related to what's going on in the
school or whether the kid is depressed
or in pain or whatever else it is these
are all obviously sane things but the
Democrats they cannot
do anything insanely and then they get
the media to fuel it and then the entire
machine the entire algorithmic machine
the way Twitter shows you the topics Ron
DeSantis hates gay people doesn't want
anyone to say gay it's complete and
abject nonsense uh here's Governor Ron
DeSantis on Tucker Carlson uh explaining
what's actually going on here
well Tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so I just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in Florida it's a free state
you can do it but I think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it uh for for young and
healthy kids especially in the State of
Florida we never had a mass Mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and I think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so I was uh I didn't want it
to be thinking that like they were told
to do this by me because I certainly
wouldn't do that and you know they talk
about oh by letting someone have a
choice to take off their mask and
welcoming that all right guys my bad we
I threw to the wrong clip there so here
is Ron DeSantis now getting into a bit
of a scuffle with the same reporter who
I just showed you from that local news
affiliate here in Florida about the
don't say gay bill
does it say that in the bill
does it say that in the bill I'm asking
I'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it doesn't matter what
critics say it says it bans classroom
instruction on sexual identity and
gender orientation for who
for grades pre-k through three so
five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-olds and um the idea that you
wouldn't be honest about that and tell
people what it actually says it's why
people don't trust people like you
because you peddle false narratives and
so we disabuse you of those narratives
and we're going to make sure that
parents are able to send their kid to
kindergarten without having some of this
stuff injected into their school
curriculum okay sorry about our little
screw up there that one's on me uh but
you can see what's going on here which
is that DeSantis really has become a
master in how to deal with the media the
fact that reporters are going up to him
and talking about the don't say gay Bill
already shows you that the reporters
have they've swallowed the narrative
right like they've taken that blue pill
and by just calling it The don't say
Gable they're already giving oxygen to
something that deserves no oxygen but
DeSantis just pushes back and that's
exactly what you must do you cannot play
their games and and they get everybody
to play their games and once you start
playing their games it's an endless
quicksand now here is the video that we
showed you a couple days because
DeSantis has just been knocking it out
of the park here's this address a couple
of days ago telling those University of
South Florida students to take off their
math
you do not have to wear those masks I
mean please honestly it's not doing
anything and we got to stop with this
coaches theater so if you want to wear
it fine but this is a this is ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at USF
okay so what happened after that well
after that then everyone said to Santa
Susan is a bully he forced the kids to
take off their mask he told them it was
their choice he didn't force anyone to
do anything you could even take you see
the kid taking it off and like the smile
on his face like oh I can breathe again
so DeSantis is really fighting the
machine right now now I want to contrast
that to
New York Governor Kathy hochel or as I
call her Kathy c word because as they
start taking masks off in New York at
least in parts of New York she's very
concerned that the mask might now get
bullied even though if they were the
ones bullying everyone for the last two
years we will not have any tolerance for
people who are questioning someone's own
personal decision to do what they want
if people want to continue wearing masks
they allowed to continue wearing masks
and I don't want any issues related to
that and I want to be very clear on that
we will not stand for any bullying or
ostracization or harassment of an
individual or a business or anyone who
chooses to wear a mask
all right so this is totally
extraordinary and I'm not just talking
about her eyebrows and she's definitely
on the Pelosi route whatever's gone
there like what did these people do
like they're just trying to look evil
it's weird but what is she really saying
there it's actually pretty amazing she's
saying we will not tolerate any bullying
now first off these are the bullies you
Kathy c word you are the bully you are
the Mandate bully you are the vaxo you
are the people that have been bullying
everyone for the last two years to do
exactly what you want but also what do
you mean as the governor we will not
tolerate any bullying of kids or people
or businesses that want to wear masks
now I'm not for bullying inherently
everyone can make whatever choice they
want that's what I have uh that's what I
believe in it's what I've pushed this
entire time right but what do you mean
we will not tolerate it are you going to
arrest students who might make fun of
other students I mean we're is that what
you're going to do are you going to
start arresting people who mock people
what do you mean we will not tolerate it
as a representative of the state so
that's what's going on in New York and
now let's throw back
to that Tucker clip with Ron DeSantis
related to uh bullying or and masks and
covet and the whole damn thing
well Tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so I just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in Florida it's a free state
you can do it but I think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it for for young and
healthy kids especially in the State of
Florida we never had a mass Mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and I think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so I was uh I didn't want it
to be thinking that like they were told
to do this by me because I certainly
wouldn't do that and you know they talk
about oh by letting someone have a
choice to take off their mask and
welcoming that choice that that's
somehow bullying Tucker bullying is
locking kids out of school which they
did bullying is forcing kids to wear
masks for eight hours a day which they
did for two years and are only stopping
now because the pollings change bullying
is kicking people out of work work
because of vaccine mandates we fought
all of those policies in Florida we
lifted people up and we liberated them
from local school boards and governments
that
that's my governor do you see what they
do they are the bullies they are the
hysterical authoritarians they're the
ones who have ruined so many people's
lives and broke these young people to
the point that even now
today you still see young healthy high
school kids wandering around in masks
because of the fear that these people
have put on so telling people hey you
don't have to wear the mask that's not
the bullying tactic they are the bullies
they do all the bad stuff and then they
call everyone else bad guys we have to
really understand what that is so that
we know how to behave better when it
happens and DeSantis really is becoming
a master of it this is a good transition
to now what's going on in New York city
so you may remember that New York City
got rid of the reign of terror of Bill
de Blasio the Socialist Maniac who
ruined New York City for about eight
years and they voted in this other
Democrat mayor Eric Adams who just took
over in the last couple months who once
again my my good liberal friends who I
suppose are well intentioned but ever
get everything wrong they said no he
won't be a radical he'll be good
yeah well here he is keeping kids
toddlers toddlers in masks if you were
talking to a four-year-old and they're
trying to explain why they have to keep
their mask on but their their
six-year-old brother doesn't what what
is your your explanation to that
four-year-old I'm sorry have you said
that because when I was in Rockaway in
the St Patrick's Day Parade I did just
that a group of parents brought me and
talked to their children and explained
uh to them I told them you're going to
be taking off your mask like your big
brothers and sisters are doing now you
know when when you have big brothers and
sisters sometimes they do things first
to make sure it's safe for you and those
children they understand it because they
trust their parents and they trust their
leadership they're not tainted like
adults you know they still feel that we
have to make the right decisions for
them and I'm with the parents I want
those masks off I said it in January but
I have to do it right to make y'all City
uh protect his children and don't close
down his City again
we really live in two different
countries perhaps it's more than two
different countries at this point but I
I don't live in the same country as that
man I don't want to live in the same
country as that man I want people like
him to have absolutely nothing to do
with me and that is why right now we are
building a giant moat around my house as
I said the other day we're putting we're
filling it with Gators and I just put an
order in we we sent the the paperwork
over to Israel I'm getting an Iron Dome
system around my house I want nothing to
do with these people now notice of
course let's just do the easy stuff up
top he didn't say one thing about
science right so there is 100 percent no
science that has come out anywhere that
it says that toddlers he's talking about
two and three-year-olds have to be uh
masked while their older brothers who
should do stuff before them uh while
they don't have to be masked okay so
there's no sign so he quoted no science
there
um and then
the line that really gets you
these kids are you talking about these
toddlers they're not tainted like adults
think about what that means what he's
right they're not tainted like adults
kids come into this world and they're
they're born free and they're they're
naive the world is just the world is
what is put in front of them and then
they need adults to teach them how to
think they need adults to teach them
what freedom is and to be able to
critically think about what's going on a
toddler cannot do that so if you force a
toddler to wear a mask and then make
them one day when you're five years old
you'll be able to take off the mask
they're just going to believe you so
they are breeding a generation of robots
and that's what they want they want a
bunch of dependent depressed robots I'm
sorry there's just no other way to look
at that I just don't know how you could
possibly see it any other way and
remember he was supposed to be the good
guy he's not as crazy as Lefty lunatic
Bill de Blasio that's what they said
um and I'm sorry if you if you now have
a child that's three years old and you
are living in New York City under the
rule of that man you're a child abuser
in essence I don't see a way around it
you're a child to be easier you are
letting the state abuse your child put
your children in Mass we know kids are
getting mouth sores it's causing delayed
speech and depression all of the stuff
you all know all this stuff and if
you're just letting them do it then uh
congratulations your kids are going to
put you in a really really cheap old age
home one day where you'll most likely be
abused by one of their friends but
there's more from New York City because
some parents have had it he said that
the good he made it seem like the
parents want this right this is what the
parents want because I love parrots uh
not exactly the truth we've got some
info here from the New York Post roughly
a hundred parents and children gathered
in front of New York's City Hall Monday
to protest continuing Mass mandates for
the city's youngest kids there is
nothing I wouldn't do to keep my
daughter safe but it is my fervent
belief a belief supported by science
that continuing to Mask two to
four-year-olds is unnecessary said Dr
Megan Martin who has two children's uh
two children ages six and four masking
tots hampers their development and must
be abandoned she argued the policy does
real harm to their education and social
growth she said and it was the oath I
took as a physician to First Do no harm
that is bringing me here today the rally
goers said they plan to file a lawsuit
that will challenge the ongoing face
covering requirement for children for
and under if you want to know sort of
what level
what level of abject [ __ ] we're
dealing with do you remember what
happened a week ago today do you guys
remember what we were doing a week ago
today remember we ordered some pizza and
some tequila and we watched that elderly
man give that ridiculous speech where he
slurred all his words yeah I remember
that that was a week ago that was the
state of the union that was Joe Biden
he's 81 years old is that right how old
is Joe Biden something like that or he's
78 81 whatever he is but the guy's
obviously not doing so great with a
bunch of other geriatric old people most
of them who have trouble standing up out
of their chairs he's 79 years old thank
you but he acts 81.
um they were all in a room that was
closed that was not outdoors and they
were hugging and kissing and spitting
all over each other Nancy Pelosi was
rubbing her evil claws together remember
that as she sat right behind old Joe
um the day before that Joe was wearing a
mask that day he didn't wear a mask the
day after he was wearing a mask again
it's all theater it's all [ __ ] I
just don't know what you what they have
done how did they take the [ __ ] thing
out of your brain that makes you think
but they did it and congratulations to
them for being very good at what they do
even though they're very evil
um but which was more dangerous which is
really think about it please scientists
if you're a scientist if you're a Media
Matters guy who watches my show please
help me please help me please show me
the study that shows me it's more
dangerous for three-year-olds to be
unmasked than Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi
please show it to me but I get that you
can't do it I know you can't but please
do I'll gladly send me a video we'll
play it here I won't even comment on it
I mean that
back to Florida where good things are
happening our Surgeon General here is
the gentleman by the name of Joseph
Joseph latapo and he has really become
an All-Star in all this we've talked
about him a bit on the show uh if his
politics were a little bit different a
young black man that's a Surgeon General
of a major state would be a huge Star
right he'd be on Newsweek he'd be on
time he'd be on covering New York Times
every day everyone would be telling you
how great he is now unfortunately he
happens to work for a scary don't say
gay conservative so you don't hear much
of this guy but he is just knocking it
out of the park defending freedom and
actually talking about where the real
science is uh here he is talking about
masks and the nonsense around masking
you know it's hard to find it's hard to
find these in in Florida you got to look
you gotta look hard but you know if you
if you know where to look you can find
them so I brought I brought this right
so unfortunately we have a country right
now where most people including I mean
this is across across the political
Spectrum think that these things are
saving lives so to the doctors who tell
you that these things save lives
ask them
ask them
you know
what What did the what did the two
randomized clinical trials that we've
done during the pandemic what did they
show
ask them that when they tell you that
these things save lives one found
nothing zero benefit
the other found a small benefit like a
tiny benefit that's you know that's a
little bit methodologically shaky and by
the way none of them
none of them found a benefit in young
people not a single one found to benefit
in young people that's the highest
quality evidence that's what it showed
lower evidence is what the CDC likes to
tell you know shaky studies shaky
methods finding 80 reductions in
infection give me a break you know I
mean come on you know nothing that we're
seeing in this in this country justifies
that kind of conclusion good doctors who
were brave enough to say what the
Science Show
got punished and that's happening and
it's still happening where people are
still holding up the illusion that these
things save lives you guys get that
feeling that I keep talking about when I
play these clips where someone tells the
truth when you hear DeSantis tell the
truth you hear our Surgeon General tell
the truth or the rare moments that
someone outside of Florida tells the
truth like it actually it feels
lightning right like you feel like a
weight is lifted off your chest because
it's like we should be hearing truth
from the people that we elect we should
be hearing truth from the people that
are in charge of these states we should
be hearing truth from our media and
everywhere else it's not that hard it
really isn't that hard it's what's right
and for some reason we're doing the
whole damn thing backwards but it was so
interesting what he said there he quoted
studies did you notice that quoted
actual studies
so again Media Matters or Washington
Post or whatever like fact check the guy
why don't you fact check the guy I think
we know why you don't in fact check the
guy he talked about the methodology
right
um he's showing you that there is no
benefit to any of this and if there was
if there was then why would Florida
which has been open for two years and
Everywhere I Go Everywhere I Go whether
I'm in Miami or I was on the other coast
last week and I've been up north and
I've been to the middle of the state
everywhere I go everything is packed
very few people are wearing masks but
you can wear one if you want to and
nobody's bullying you for it wouldn't
the numbers be completely out of control
the morgs be overrun Florida has the
second oldest population in the United
States
etc
etc it just never ends but Florida just
has to keep leading and that's exactly
what it's doing we've got some more info
here from the New York Post Florida will
become the first state in the nation to
formally recommend against covid-19
vaccines for healthy children a local
official said Monday Florida Surgeon
General Joseph ladapo who you just saw
there announced the move which would
defy guidance issued by the federal
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention and that all uh that all
children ages five to seven should be
vaccinated
now it's funny because uh what Florida
does everyone ends up doing two years
later so most likely this is what's
going to happen everywhere else uh we
shall see but it's like this this is
what I mean about two countries this is
absolutely what I mean about two
countries it's like you can either live
in a place where you have a New York
city mayor uh telling you that we're
going to mass two-year-olds for no
reason other than he I think he wants to
abuse children I I cannot see it any
other way no science supports it two
years after two two weeks to flatten the
curve so you can either live in that
City or you can live his Governor Kathy
seaward in a place where uh she's now
mostly worried that the masks are going
to be bullied these people are they're
so backwards it's extraordinary uh let's
give Dr latapo a little more credit
today uh here he is talking about the
new guidance here in Florida and he is
not happy with fauci in the CDC it's
really been a tragedy that my colleagues
my physician colleagues have decided
that it's more important to stick with
whatever the CDC or Dr fauci is saying
then relying on their clinical wisdom
experience and scientific expertise
which is what doctors usually do so now
doctors who practice medicine in the way
way that they think is most appropriate
to their for their patients when they're
when they receive pushback from
hospitals we have an Avenue for them to
to file a complaint with our agency for
health care administration that they
that the hospital is interfering with
their ability and their clinical
judgment in terms of what's best for
their patients isn't it also the tone
that he talks with where it's like oh it
actually just kind of feels honest and
it doesn't feel like he's a [ __ ]
artist or trying to control you it's not
just that he's talking about the studies
and that it's couched in the idea of
that we should all make choices for
ourselves and and doctors should follow
the science not follow fouchy it's also
just like the general feeling like he
comes off as a decent guy now go back
later and watch that video of Kathy
hochel again with the crazy eyebrows uh
talking about bullying when she is the
biggest bully in all of New York
I just want nothing to do with these
people in case that is not clear a
couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com Owen says every
day DeSantis pushes me further and
further to finding a job in Florida yeah
look
I assume if you're a member of the
Reuben report Community you're going to
vote the right way but like there's room
in Florida there's a booming economy
here which is not happening in the rest
of the country we want more good people
here I think I mentioned this the other
day but when I saw DeSantis speak at an
event a few days ago he mentioned that
when he came into office there were 300
000 more registered Democrats than
Republicans he's only been office for a
couple years and now there are about a
hundred thousand more registered
Republicans than Democrats so there's a
huge sea change here and it's not
because people hate science and it's not
because people hate gays or anything
else it's because people want to live
freely so so get a job here move your
family here bring your resources and
your love of life and let's keep making
this place better yeah awesome uh
gellarish says when I was in third grade
I still thought girls had cooties wait
girls don't have cooties
we're gonna have to get fact check on
that one yes these crazy people like
legitimately crazy people I mean you
just really have to think about it and
maybe I'm sort of on this because I just
as I said I went to my niece's
seven-year-old birthday party at this
place and we're making the Silly String
and we're painting and we're playing
these squishy balls and they like the uh
the puppets you know these things they
like it's interesting because kids right
now they seem to all love this tactile
stuff that you actually touch or pull or
or mush around in your hands and I think
that's partly because they're on iPads
all day long and they're at screens all
day long and zoom and all that so kids
in reality they want some reality but
the idea that you would start talking to
seven-year-olds about gender identity or
sexuality it's it's it has nothing to do
with them and and yes if you were in the
rare rare rare let's say one percent
case where Maybe
your seven-year-old child wanted to talk
to you about gender identity or
sexuality that should be done with you
as the parent not done at school by some
government employee it's just so obvious
and and it's just another one of those
things where they have lied and they're
so over the top and they're lying and
they confuse so many so many people it's
just so Twisted it's so Twisted man what
are we gonna do about it Abe says what
do you suggest for those of us in blue
states that are still sane but cannot
afford to just pack up and leave well
first off I've got the jar right here
and I have mentioned New York a couple
times so I'm going to put some more cash
in the jar this is the leave Cali fund
and at the end of the year I am going to
give a whole bunch of cash and I'll
throw in a couple extra thousand dollars
myself to just move somebody like I just
want somebody to get the hell out of
California and come here to Florida you
don't have to come to Florida
realistically it's someone that comes to
Florida maybe you can go to Texas or
Tennessee but I just want to give
someone here I'm putting in another
fiber okay because I just want good
people here but your question's a good
one because look not it's very difficult
to move people have all sorts of of
their own issues right like you might
have family uh elderly parents you might
have young cousins whatever it is like
you might have a business that you
started there although if you have a
business that you started in a place
like California it's probably not going
that well but we all have our own
considerations that's the point I mean
trust me when I decided to make the move
David actually was not as enthused as I
was at first I had to make sure that my
entire team wanted to come with me I was
a little worried about that once I said
it to everybody they were like yes let's
go tomorrow okay so it all kind of
worked out but it's just not easy to
move in general and it costs a lot of
money to move all your stuff and you
know there's all and you have to rebuild
a network of friends and rebuild a
business Network and you have to find a
new dentist and a new hair stylist and
all of those things like it's not the
easiest thing but I would say at this
point
at this point the country is so broken
and so split and I don't know I just
don't know I don't say this with Glee
but I just don't know what makes us the
United States of America anymore I I
don't want anything to do with anything
that goes on in California and I don't
want any of those bad ideas infecting
this state and the states the good
states are going to have to continue to
figure out how do we protect our
freedoms in the face of this
never-ending Federal encroachment in the
face of of big Tech lies and media lives
and everything else so if you're really
really stuck there I the best you can do
I think is build a really good community
of people around you whether that's
church or synagogue or sports or
whatever and and try not to and try to
get your kids out of school if you're a
parent I mean I would say you know it's
not like everyone wants to be a
homeschooler but now there's these pods
like there there are ways that you can
get some of the power back into your
hands but
but the real thing is like figure out a
way to get out if you can I just don't
see how it turns around I just don't see
it
um and by the way that's not that's not
really depressing it's not this is the
way it was all set up to be and it's
just becoming more and more Stark and
enough people are going to move and then
and then of course the blue States will
declare war on the red States because
they're going to be jealous of the
freedom and the success and all that but
I think we got a couple years on that
one anywho uh guys don't forget to
pre-order don't burn this country at
daveruben.com book I will be spending
the next five hours reading chapters
four through six I believe uh and the
audiobook will be out as well on April
12th in the year 2022 uh as always you
can play along in the live chat at
reubenreport.locals.com and part one of
my interview with Nikki Haley former u s
ambassador to the UN is up on YouTube
and on Rumble right now the full thing
is already up on locals totally ad free
and as I said we we get into the Russia
Ukraine thing but I tried to do it at
sort of a high level thing not every
little nitty-gritty we did some 101
stuff on the history of the area and
Putin's Ambitions but then really what
we talked about was policy like what are
sane policies what are ways that you can
have a foreign policy that makes sense
so that your interests are protected so
that you're not encroaching on other
people but you can also do some good
things in the world how do you blend
that with you know a more libertarian
approach of just stay out of people's
way and let let other countries do what
they want I think it's a really
interesting conversation and I'm fairly
certain you will dig it on that note I
have to stop talking for an hour because
I got a long afternoon of talking hope
you enjoyed the show have a great day we
will be back tomorrow